est ce qu'il est possible de promettre
aux québécois un temps d'attendre
maximum aux urgences avant de voir un
médecin si oui combien de temps c'est
pas la bonne engagement à prendre pour
leur donner un autre endroit que
l'urgence pour aller se faire soigner
comme les super clean donc pour les
urgences vont travailler sur un autre
option que l'urgence
moi je me méfie énormément de ça parce
que ce qu'il faut organiser c'est que
les gens aillent pas aux urgences c'est
ça qui va marcher ses sacs ont proposé
deux noms
jeudi je veux pas m'avancer la
crédibilité de ces propositions là et je
pense que si on parle de voir un médecin
pour avoir réglé son problème
90 minutes ça existe ailleurs comment on
y aller il faut que les médecins de
famille en fasse beaucoup plus en
première ligne donc vous êtes c'est ça
passait par une promesse qui reste vous
poursuivre pendant quatre heures salle
ce qui est important c'est tout ce qui
vient avant qui va nous permettre
d'arrêter de prendre l'urgence comme une
porte d'entrée et pour nous c'est
l'ouverture des clsc 24 heures 7 jours
ce n'est donc mais pas de 90 minutes
pour voir un médecin
ben écoutez moi je pense qu'entre s'est
laissé tu peux le voir très rapidement
est ce que le gouvernement du québec un
contrôle sur le prix de l'essence qui
ressemblent souvent de la collusion très
peu et on peut par exemple analyser les
diverses composantes du prime on a très
peu de contrôles de contrôle direct la
meilleure option pour les québécois
c'est de poser le plus beau geste de
nationalisme économique et de choisir le
véhicule électrique maintenant écouter
tous les mardis ou mercredis ça monte de
10 m à montréal c'est clair il a choisi
d'être impuissant nous nous proposons
que
l'office de protection du consommateur
se donne des moyens d'enquêté de
sanctions parce que le bureau de la
concurrence du canada qui devrait s'en
occuper s'en occupe il faut la seule
chose qu'on peut faire que le
gouvernement fédéral se doit aussi de
collusion mais sincèrement ça fait
partie du privé ne pas beaucoup de
contrôler le prix de l'essence c'est
quelque chose qui frappe fort et québec
solidaire on s'en vient avec un plan de
transition énergétique qui va tout aussi
frappé fort ok mais pour contrôler pour
les consommateurs de ce qu'on ait un
contrôle sur ce que font les détaillants
je pense que les gouvernements très peu
de contrôles cdci d'ailleurs